[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing a piece
of hogwarts history the tri was a
tournament more specifically
we're going to be diving all the way
back to the year 1792
the last year the tournament ran before
when harry ends up participating the
tournament dates back
700 years in total and managed to run
uninhibited until 1792
so what prompted this 200-year hiatus
let's start with a bit of history the
triwizard tournament was first
established some seven hundred years ago
as a friendly competition between the
three largest european schools of
wizardry
hogwarts bobaton and durmstrang
a champion was selected to represent
each school
and the three champions competed in
three magical tasks
the schools took it in turns to host the
tournament once every five years
and it was generally agreed to be a most
excellent way
of establishing ties between young
witches and wizards
of different nationalities the triwizard
tournament
certainly becomes an integral part of
the harry potter story
and is the main plot driver in the
goblet of fire we see harry
and the other champions fighting for
their school's honor
competing in three tasks designed to
test the champion's courage
intelligence resourcefulness and magical
ability
so what happened in 1792
we know that each time the tournament is
held the challenges differ
and it just so happens that in 1792
one of the challenges involved a
cockatrice a giant magical beast
resembling a rooster with a lizard's
tail the participants were meant to
capture the cockatrice in question
and well things didn't go exactly
according to plan
with the dangerous creature on the loose
no one was safe
and that included three judges of the
tournament the heads of hogwarts
durmstrang and bobitol well the heads of
the participating schools are always in
the panel
because all three of them were injured
during the tournament of 1792
when a cockatrice the champions were
supposed to be catching
went on the rampage it's all in hogwarts
a history
after this happened it was exceedingly
difficult to get the tournament started
again
as the challenges seem to pose a
significant danger
to the general public this is reinforced
by dumbledore
there have been several attempts over
the centuries to reinstate the
tournament
dumbledore continued none of which has
been very successful
however our only departments of
international magical cooperation
and magical games and sports have
decided the time is ripe
for another attempt we've worked hard
over the summer
to ensure that this time no champion
will find himself
or herself in mortal danger however as
we know
despite their best efforts to stop
anyone else getting hurt from the
triwizard tournament
it claimed another victim in cedric
diggory however
in the tournament organizers defense
there was a lot going on that year
and that's it for this video if you
enjoy the content please
like the video and subscribe to the
channel
until next time you're a wizard harry
you